The Carthus Sandworm
It wasn't always here, this deep underground.
It originally appeared a few layers higher, rocketing through the Catacombs of Carthus,
but the Carthus Grave Wardens devised a way to drive it out.
With clever use of lightning resistant yellow bug pellets,
they repelled the sand worm so effectively that it tumbled deep below to its new home in the smoldering lake,
and if you look carefully you can actually see how much of its body is comprised of its victims,
and it's these Karthus corpses that we're discussing today
because the sand worm exists at the end of the Carthus timeline,
and we're more interested in the beginning,
in what happened to the sand kingdom above the Catacombs,
the empire that would conquer the world.
Theoretically, when you exit the Carthus Catacombs
you should be faced with rolling sand dunes and a blistering sun,
But you're not you're kind of met with the stark opposite when you see Farron Swamp.
That's strange and I'll explain why that is at the end of this video,
but for now, I want you to imagine this arid desert kingdom setting because that is the kingdom that we're piecing together.
This was an empire that was won by the warriors of Carthus.
Almost every civilization in Souls has this single characterizing drive that motivates their warriors.
Mirrah is driven by knighthood and honor; Demon Kind is driven by this desperate need for survival,
and the Warriors of Carthus were characterized by their lust for victory.
This inspired a culture that is focused on combat techniques
and the ability to achieve victory through any means necessary.
With their own brand of sharpened titanite, warriors of Carthus fought with heavy curved swords;
some of which were specifically designed to curve around the shields of their enemies.
If they found themselves at a distance from their enemy,
they would peg these small machetes at them called kukri,
and if they were in melee range,
they could use their blood rings to sort of dash around the battlefield like a cloud of sand.
There's more to their techniques.
With the development of spells such as Carthus Flame arc and Carthus Beacon,
they developed a school of supplemental pyromancy that was entirely divergent from other forms.
So in the t ree of pyromancy, there was a branch of Carthus pyromancies,
and no pyromancy captured their love of victory quite like the spell Acid Surge did.
Pyromancy of Carthus of the Sands emits an acid which corrodes weapons and armor.
Carthus' swordsmen attached great value to victory and would not shun the use of such pyromancies.
For where is the honor in death and scoured bones?
In addition to this one, there was the Beacon Pyromancy, which likens Carthus' aggression to an uncontrollable fire.
This spell rewards you for being recklessly offensive,
and was activated during war to serve as this silent secret signal for attack.
So with tools such as these,
they toppled other kingdoms and likely used their resources to fuel their own kingdom.
So compare Carthus' ideology to a place like Mirrah.
Like Mirrah, Carthus is this war-torn country that revolves around its fighters.
But in contrast, Mirrah has this huge focus on knighthood and honor
to the point where they would actively avoid using magic because it would be seen as unknightly.
To do so, they would only ever use magic the only time they truly needed it, to face the magic of an enemy.
A Carthus warrior, on the other hand, would imbue his pre-sharpened sword with fire,
buff himself with a secret pyromancy art,
throw a machete at your face,
cast a cloud of acid to eat away at your weapons,
roll around you as this invisible, invincible cloud of sand,
and leave his shield ignoring Shotel red with your blood.
A Carthus Warrior is basically the kind of dude summons at the Pontiff's Arena.
It's someone who has min maxed all of their stats,
someone who spends a minute buffing themselves before the duel,
and who drinks Estus if they're about to lose.
But moving on,
in Souls, a crown is representative of the power and the influence that you wield.
It's the sign of a rightful monarch, and that was a huge theme in Dark Souls 2,
and it's kind of represented in Dark Souls 3 by Wolnir who brought rightful Lords to their knees,
ground their crowns to dust, and conquered them all.
Their crowns became one, kind of like in the Dark Souls 2 cinematic
and their kingdoms became his as well,
with Wolnir becoming the one High Lord of a vast, vast empire.
His warriors lived for their High Lord Wolnir,
who was the conqueror of most kingdoms known to their people.
And while Wolnir definitely didn't have much respect for monarchs,
Wolnir did respect prowess with the blade.
Below the catacombs,
we loot the Black Blade, which is a short katana that was once wielded with a rare technique.
The swordsman who wielded it was, and I quote, a distinguished guest of High Lord Wolnir,
though considering his blade is found in the crypts. Now. I'm kind of thinking that his distinguished guests might be dead,
and that sort of ties into our next point.
Wolnir was motivated by a unique goal, called a wish in the Japanese text.
He didn't just want to conquer kingdoms. He specifically wanted to become the last of the dead,
to outlive all,
to conquer kingdoms was kind of just a byproduct of this, and
so it was that his main goal was to sentence countless souls to death,
and this seems to have included a bunch of clerics,
who possessed some truly powerful artifacts of the Way of White.
I count three holy bracelets and a divine greatsword,
so these would come in handy for Wolnir later in life.
Because true to the Carthus ethos of victory at all costs,
Wolnir began experimenting with the Abyss.
This resulted in new dark pyromancies,
but Wolnir slipped a lot further than he intended
and he experienced a fear of true darkness,
and he clung to the strength of the gods for the first time in his life.
Note the English description says that warm their pleaded with the gods. No. Wolnir didn't plead that's not in his character at all.
Instead, the Japanese clarifies that he clung to the power of the gods
because their divinity naturally defies the Abyss,
and it was these items, these artifacts of the gods, that were imbued with power.
It wasn't necessarily Wolnir who had faith.
So thanks to these holy bracelets
and the sword that he pillaged from those Way of White clerics that he killed,
Wolnir was able to fight off being completely consumed by the Abyss,
and it's unclear how present he was in his kingdom, henceforth.
But I think he still had some influence over his kingdom
because afterwards, his grave wardens were able to pioneer new pyromancies.
Spells that imparted the will of humanity to fire,
like Black Serpent, which traces along the ground as if it had a life of its own.
But perhaps it was precisely these events,
this tinkering with the Abyss, that would draw the Abyss Watchers to the kingdom of Carthus
to stand bow to the dark that was rising there
In Dark Souls 3, it's not just time that's convoluted,
it's the geography of the world as well.
We mentioned at the start that it's not a sand kingdom that exists above the Catacombs of Carthus as it should in Dark Souls 3.
Instead, I think Farron swamp exists above the Catacombs of Carthus because the two places are linked.
That it was the Abyss Watchers of Farron who trampled upon Wolnir's Abyss putting an end to the sand kingdom of Carthus,
and that it was likely Wolnir who dragged the Abyss Watchers with him.
We go over that point a little bit more in this video which features 10 secrets of war from the Souls Series,
so check it out, and join me as we wrap up all of the remaining lore of this series
because the Dark Souls series is at its end for now, and hopefully we learn a little bit more about our future at E3.
I'm so excited for that. But for now, I'll see you next time.